STEPHANIE WONG:
Today, we're talking
about carbon-free energy, a
new podcast from our SREs,
and the ultimate
guide to speech AI.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and welcome
to "This Week on Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Securing around the
clock carbon-free energy
isn't just important for Google.
It's also critical for the
world to successfully tackle
the urgent challenge
of climate change.
While rapid progress and
cost-effective carbon-free
energy technology
has put the prospect
of decarbonized electricity
grids within reach,
it's not inevitable.
And that's why we are committed
to working with stakeholders
across the globe to advocate for
policies that accelerate grid
decarbonization for everyone.
Check out the blog to join us.
We're excited to announce
the launch of the Google SRE
prodcast, an interview
style podcast
where site reliability
engineers at Google
discuss key SRE
concepts and share
their experiences, advice, and
strong opinions, along the way.
Since early 2016,
SREs at Google had
been producing and listening
to an internal version
of the podcast.
This year, we decided to think
bigger and share insights
from Google SREs with
the wider SRE community.
Thanks to AI, speaking out
loud has become not only
a primary way of communicating
with machines, like when
you tell your smartphone
to send a text
or ask your smart speaker
about the weather,
but also enriching
human interactions,
such as generating
captions in near real time
during a video meeting.
Head to the blog to
explore some of the most
interesting and practical
applications of speech
technology as well
as the Google Cloud
tools that make building
these sorts of apps possible.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.